first my brain dump
nursing care homes are supposed to be a
sanctuary to our most cherished and
elderly loved ones so they can live out
their lives in comfort safety and
dignity at the beginning of the
carnivorous pandemic the leader is
responsible for protecting that comfort
safety and dignity repeatedly told us
things like this
right from the start we've tried to
throw a protective ring around our care
homes we'll keep working to strengthen
the protective ring that we've cast
around all our care homes
well we absolutely did throw a
protective ring around social care that
was britain's health secretary matt
hancock at the time but that was a lie
there was no protective ring in fact
there was a complete opposite a deadly
decision-making fiasco that removed
protection from nursing homes and turned
them into human slaughter houses in a
monumentally stupid policy tens of
thousands of elderly patients were sent
from hospitals back to their homes
without being tested to see if they had
the killer virus that wrought its worst
damage on the elderly kobe spread
through those nursing homes like
wildfire causing countless more deaths
and should have ever been allowed to
happen the same thing happened in new
york with ashamed at former governor
andrew cuomo once lauded as a
cool-headed hero of the pandemic not
only did this too but then lied about
the number of people who died
in the uk up to 30 000 people and feared
to have died in nursing homes partly
because of this negligence they weren't
even asked to isolate when they got back
to those homes from hospitals having not
been tested just think about that no
testing no isolation
and this wasn't a tragic accident this
was deliberate government policy
now the uk's high court has today ruled
that the policy broke the law so boris
johnson's government already reeling
from the partygate scandal which saw him
personally find is facing further
charges of behaving like common
criminals during the crisis
disgraced former health secretary matt
hancock who resigned for breaking
lockdown rules himself that he'd helped
to make
said ministers have been absolved
they haven't they got it horribly
tragically wrong
and they can't say they weren't warned
by people at the time
when the health secretary and prime
minister
keep claiming that they put a protective
ring around our care homes that is just
a complete lie isn't it because if they
had you wouldn't have 30 000 people
residents dying and you wouldn't have
469 social care workers dying that's not
a protective ring we have really stepped
up uh to support care and support local
authorities and support
they didn't step up
and it's all a lie as has now been
proven in the high court at the time
boris johnson tried to even blame
nursing home staff for not following
protocols but they did follow protocols
it was the protocols laid down by the
government that cost an untold number of
lives including many of the selfless and
heroic staff boris johnson tried to
blame
today johnson did what he always does he
said it wasn't his fault
the thing that we didn't know in
particular uh mr speaker uh was uh that
kobe could be transmitted
asymptomatically in in the way that it
was and uh and that was something that i
wish we had known more about at the time
he didn't know that's what he always
says isn't it didn't know about the
parties didn't know about asymptotic
transmission
but is that true prime minister it's not
is it because your own chief scientific
advisor speaking in march 2020 right at
the beginning of the pandemic said this
it looks quite likely that there is is
some degree of asymptomatic transmission
there's definitely quite a lot of
transmission very early in the disease
when they're very mild symptoms
that's the government's chief scientific
advisor
in march 2020 so you knew boris johnson
he knew
once again he's refusing to face up to
his own mistakes in this case their
horrifying consequences he and his
government didn't just fail our elderly
they killed them
their terrible policy let kovid rip
through nursing homes and that led to
thousands of unnecessary deaths there
will be many terrible legacies from this
pandemic but this one may be the most
shameful and avoidable
and from incompetence in government to
indecency the deputy leader of the
british opposition party has been
smeared in a nasty sexist anonymous
newspaper briefing suggesting she
deliberately crosses and uncrosses her
legs to distract boris johnson in the
house of commons
an unnamed conservative mp accused
angela rayner of a ploy to put the prime
minister off his stride evoking the
famous scene involving sharon stone in
the movie basic instinct
the mp told the man on sunday she knows
she can't compete with boris's oxford
union debating training but she has
other skills which he lacks
for god's sake well first of all you
don't need to flash a pair of hot legs
to get one over boris johnson in
parliament given how poorly he's
performing at the moment a barely
functioning brain will suffice
secondly angela rayne is a very smart
very feisty cookie who deserves a lot
better than this pathetic misogynistic
nonsense as do all female politicians
but it's what happened next that causes
me even more concern because the speaker
of the house of commons lindsey hoyle
summons the editor of the mail on sunday
to discuss the story because he found
the defensive an absurd command which
the newspaper rightly rejected it's not
the paper that's at fault here it's the
repellent mp who made the slur in the
first place speaker hoyle should get
back in his box focus on finding out who
his malevolent miscreant mp was and then
discipline him for abusing parliamentary
standards of conduct he should leave the
free press to do their jobs without such
unacceptable political interference even
if it occasionally offends him in fact
no i think about it particularly if it
occasionally offends him
police have released sensational footage
of the events before during after the
appalling shooting of a young female in
a cinematographer on a low budget
western in the santa fe desert the death
of helena hutchins on the set of joel
d'souza's rust is one of the most
appalling tragedies in hollywood history
i don't doubt for a moment it was an
accident nobody deliberately killed her
but she died leaving a grief-stricken
husband and young child and the person
who was holding the gun that killed her
was the movie star alec baldwin in the
new footage baldwin can be seen pointing
the gun around on set
and then later reacting with horror when
he's told that hutchins has died
i do have some very unfortunate news to
tell you
she didn't make it
i'm sure he felt terrible we all would
in that position but if you've been
following his story for the past six
months as i have you might be forgiven
for thinking alec baldwin was the real
victim here
i wanted to take a moment to
say thank you to all of the people who
sent me such kind words and
you know
best wishes and strength and hope and
prayers and so forth and thoughts and
lots of encouragement
oh good for you i'm glad you're being
encouraged that's like a humble brag
oscar acceptance speech isn't it
baldwin's self-pity pr tool has been a
deeply unedifying self-centered and
pretty ghastly attempt to save his
career he insists this tragedy had
nothing to do with him that he was in no
way responsible for that gun firing and
killing helena hutchins but for all his
bluster the story is far from over and
frankly the idea that it's got nothing
to do with baldwin is patently absurd he
held the gun that fired the bullet that
killed this young woman
the hollywood actors union is pretty
clear about this actors should always
check guns to ensure they don't have
real bullets
and in this case they could have used a
fake rubber gun on the set of rust
that's always the safest option police
have now revealed text messages sent by
russ prop master sarah zachary which
suggests it was baldwin himself who
always wanted to take risks alex never
liked anything fake like guns and even
the rubber knife she said he always
wanted the real knife he always wanted
his real gun
baldwin's failure to take any personal
responsibility for this horrific
incident is shameful he has a lot of
questions left to answer and i suggest
the only talking he now does is not on
instagram but to the police
well staying with tinsel towns most
terrible it's the world's most gruesome
twosome in the bile of the century
those supreme narcissists johnny depp
and amber heard all of each other and
called again trading vicious ugly claim
and counterclaim over who was more
abusive to the other one and with the
war raging a pandemic still going and
the inflation soaring the spectacle of
this pair of deluded self-obsessed
thespians once again acting up their
marriage drama for public delectation
makes me vomit but there is one positive
thing out of all this that did catch my
eye crowds of depths fans have gathered
outside court to support the embattled
star they're apparently called the
dempsters and one of them has brought
along two emotional support alpacas she
told reporters she hoped it would calm
johnny down and brighten his day now
it's not clear if depp even knows
they're there these alpacas i did a bit
of research and i said to my team you
know we should get into this story and
you know what
they came good because
i turned up today and i discovered that
after my stressful week launching piers
morgan and censored when i'm feeling
tense and need to calm and just relax
and chill
i've got my own alpacas
not from the depthsters but from
jess who's brought them for me jess how
are you i'm good how are you introduce
me this is margarita this is margarita
the one that's sitting down his tests
and i'm told margaret is a bit more
friendly is that right yeah she's the
friendly one can i can i stroke on the
back of the neck i'm hi margarita i do
love a nice margarita i have to say um
and and they can bring me calm and
hopefully soothe my my nerves my tension
yeah so just being around alpacas i
think gives you something to focus on so
it sort of takes you away mentally from
whatever you're feeling in your head
i can actually stop starting to feel it
and they can actually encourage
leadership skills yeah right i think so
because they sort of well you have to
lead them around the field one way or
another so you have to sort of take
charge otherwise they'll take you
forward so they can cure my anxiety my
stress my tension they can teach me how
to lead a group of people yeah they
sound perfect for peers morgan and
sensitive are they disagreeable bad
tempered um
they're just stubborn
the ones on the floor stubborn
this sounds even more perfect i love
their signs here's morgan uncensored and
i can quite see now i've been in the
presence of these wonderful animals by
johnny depp maybe maybe getting some
comfort from just being around alpacas
how wonderful animals they are